fútbol porque volvió la Champions League
Así es dos duros abrieron los octavos de
final de la competición a nivel de
Clubes más importante del mundo nos
centramos en el enfrentamiento entre el
psg y el Bayern de Múnich en el parque
de Los Príncipes que terminó con
Victoria para los alemanes allí en París
estuvo nuestra periodista Natalia Ruiz
giraldo que nos tiene la crónica del
encuentro
es la bestia negra del París Saint
Germán centrocampista marcó el único gol
de este partido pero dio una victoria
muy importante a la Bayern Munich el
Bayern Munich que finalmente pues dominó
este partido de principio a fin con una
presión muy fuerte muy arriba sobre todo
durante el primer tiempo anulando todas
las posibilidades de París de poder
llegar a la portería de somer Neymar y a
Messi que no lograron conectar y sobre
todo pues se notaba la falta de kilian
mbappé especialmente en ese primer
tiempo el gol llegaría en la segundo
tiempo en el minuto 53 un pase de Davis
al segundo palo que finalmente coman
logró muy bien definir ante el arquero
donnaru cuatro minutos más tarde
entraría por fin kilian mbappé ante el
rugido de este parque de Los Príncipes y
fue el hombre que le dio esa
peligrosidad que tanto le faltaba a
París de hecho marcó dos goles que
terminaron siendo anulados por estar
fuera del lugar sin embargo después de
esto ya el Bayer otra vez volvió a
quedarse en los últimos minutos con el
control de la pelota y dejando así ya
pues con París perdiendo este partido
Esta es la tercera derrota de los
parisinos en tan solo siete días Muchas
cosas por resolver antes de el partido
de vuelta que será el próximo ocho de
marzo en
múnichero el Milan consiguió una
victoria balsámica ante el tottenham
triunfo por la mínima con un gol
tempranero de Díaz segundo partido
ganaron de manera consecutiva para un
Milán que venía de siete encuentros sin
levantar los brazos es además su primer
triunfo en una eliminatoria de Champions
League en 11 años para mañana otros dos
partidos el brujas recibió el benfica y
el se mide al Chelsea en Alemania
argentino Enzo Fernández está convocado
con los de Londres